[Applause]
the i-15 the scene of a chaotic police
chase
now it ended with one nhp trooper
airlifted to umc
a very dangerous and dramatic situation
on the 15 unfolded just a few hours ago
thanks for joining us here at six
i'm denise faldis and i'm brian loftis
one nhp trooper involved in a car chase
involving a carjacker all happened
just after 12 30 p.m according to a
union official
the suspect is dead we have team
coverage tonight let's take it to
victoria saha
who is joining us live near i-15 and
sahara
victoria hey brian the northbound lanes
just opened up less than an hour ago but
you can see the southbound lane
is still empty no traffic is allowed
there except that dozens of police cars
you see there
still trying to piece together what
happened we do know that the trooper is
injured
and the suspect did not survive after a
20 minute chase within
the last couple of hours we received new
information from the nevada association
of public safety officers
they tell us the chase started around 12
30 this afternoon
and involved parole and probation trying
to stop a woman
troopers jumped in to help and as one
was laying down spike strips
we're told the female suspect hit him
with her car sending him through the
windshield multiple authorities stopped
that suspect and believed she was going
for the downed trooper's weapon
they opened fire and she didn't survive
a short time later chopra landed on the
interstate
presumably to take that trooper to umc
people nearby
couldn't believe what they heard
i'm glad no bullets flew over here and
hit me you know what i mean because
the police they were just shooting on
like 20 or 30 times
keys tells us he had his business here
for a couple of years and he has never
seen anything like this happen
now it's been about you know six hours
since this highway closed down again
still a very active scene on the
southbound lane you can see
the crime tape was just but down but
that lane is still closed and
is expected to be closed for the next
couple of hours reporting live near
i-15 and sahara avenue exit victoria
saha 8 news now
victoria thank you for that there's so
many things to cover tonight let's check
in now with joe moeller joe is reporting
live from
ufc take it away joe
as the day goes on there's nhp troopers
who continue to wait outside of umc for
any sort of
update on this trooper who was flown
here to umc earlier this afternoon last
listed in critical condition
fighting for his life i'll give you a
live look here outside the hospital
we've watched
several troopers wait outside the east
entrance here
waiting for that update now just before
two this afternoon we watched as family
of
the trooper involved came here to umc
travis smacka from nhp says this is a
difficult time for their force he says
they are all
very close he's a member of our family
uh
i've actually i i've worked up with him
several years when
together on when we were both both
working on the overnight shift
and it's it's hard to really concentrate
anything else you're just here just
hoping
you're just giving trying to hope that
he recovers
now smacking said the the trooper has
been with the force for several years
but did not say
exactly for how long now back out here
live you're taking another look at the
east side of the umc
entrance again the family of that
trooper involved is here as well inside
of the hospital
waiting just like the troopers who are
outside waiting for that update
again listed in critical new edition
fighting for his life tonight as soon as
we are able to get some sort of update
on the condition of course we'll pass it
along reporting live outside of umc joe
mohler 8 news now
joe thanks the situation has impacted
traffic all across
i-15 now even though the northbound of
the 15 freeway has reopened
there are still parts of the freeway
that remain closed so let's check in now
with arko mana with a closer look at
some of the impacts on traffic orca
well denise it was really a mess all
afternoon out here on the interstate
but as you can see the northbound lanes
of the i-15 have finally
reopened but this is what it looked like
earlier
traffic was backed up all along the i-15
for hours causing some major traffic
headaches
all afternoon at the i-15 in russell
cars were barely moving
going bumper to bumper again this all
unfolded after police say an nhp trooper
was injured
in a car chase further north we're being
told the southbound lanes at sahara
are still closed right now additional
alerts from the rtc
indicate that access to southbound i-15
is also shut off
from craig road to spring mountain road
and i-15 southbound between 215 and
tropical and spring mountain
is also close metro police say that they
are expecting the southbound
i-15 closures to stay that way for
several hours we'll keep our eye on the
roads
and bring you any updates both on air
and online reporting live at i-15 and
russell tonight
orca manna 8 news now